first off get that pan really nice and
hot
these are
sirloin steaks
sear it in the pan with all that fat on
i'll add flavor
salt and pepper
couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan
nice and hot
hold up the steak
and lay it in always lay away
through the panna
a little shake and it stops the steak
from sticking we're looking for color
and if it sticks it's gonna burn
while the steaks are cooking i can get
on with my super quick marinade
now two tablespoons of
meat soup paste that's a fermented
soybean that gives a really nice sort of
rich
sweetness
tablespoon of sugar
a couple of tablespoons rice wine that
gives it a really nice vinegary
kick a couple tablespoons of olive oil
salt and pepper
i'm looking for a nice sort of thick
rich marinade
marinade done it's time to turn the
steaks
sort the pan
and to give the steaks a little base all
we're doing every time is just adding
more more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back and really
melt all that fat down
off of the gas
take them out just take your knife
see all that fat there just slice that
off
i don't want any of that
now
in
to the marinade
[Music]
useful
tacos are one of mexico's most popular
street foods they've been made from beef
pork chicken or fish and are loaded up
with amazing sauces and spices
now i want something sort of pickly
cabbage these are
um chinese cabbages slice it in half
and look at it really crisp and really
tasty
we're going to slice that into quarters
and then just shred it and take your
time
you think of cabbage here and you think
of sort of braised
overcooked cabbage nothing worse
but attacker you want freshness
a little season of chili flakes
they sort of discreetly
give it a little bit of heat
a little touch
of rice wine vinegar
if you haven't got that
fresh lemon juice a small drop of
toasted sesame seed oil
give that
a really good mix
now i need something to sort of bring it
together we take some wasabi paste very
hot very spicy a sort of thumbnail size
i'm gonna mix that
with a couple of tablespoons of
mayonnaise
and give that a really good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them
and then shape them actually place it
on
the gas ring
use some tongs
so it's not to burn yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan
from there
i'm just gonna place it
on the rolling pin
literally 30 seconds
as it cools down
the great thing about serving tacos is
people can fill them themselves just the
way they want them
cabbage
just squeeze out wet marinade
a nice rustic little mountain
mayonnaise
on wait you see
how soft
and delicious and almost sort of
melting in the mouth texture we've got
on this amazing sirloin
it's got that really nice
sear around the outside it's just nice
and pink in the middle
start off with my
crispy shell
back of the spoon
with the wasabi mayonnaise
inside
taco
and just sprinkle
that delicious
pickled cabbage
and then just
start lining my taco three or four
slices
touch more
on my spicy
layer
and that is how i'd make
the perfect taco
[Music]
this is like a triple omelette but a lot
more ingredients than a normal mesh
we'll start off with some lovely smoked
bacon slice
the bacon bacon in
those salts
little touch of pepper
start off on a high heat get that bacon
really nice and crispy
otherwise you just boil the bacon and
it's got that soft unpleasant texture in
the frittata
turn down the gas and now start adding
your veg
roughly chop a red pepper and add it to
the pan
the peppers and the bacon take the
longest so they've always got to go in
first
now soaking them off
the peppers have been cooked now from
that sort of rendered fat from the bacon
and then the spring onions
just bunch them up
slice them i want them on an angle
so they come like little green diamonds
spring onions in
now for the eggs
cracking the eggs
for that size pan
seven or eight eggs
i want to fill it right to the very top
and more importantly when i
turn this out
i want it like a gato nice and thick so
slice through and see all those
wonderful verge
[Music]
i'm gonna season the eggs
with some parmesan cheese be quite
generous because it adds a really nice
saltiness
[Music]
fresh ground pepper and then whisk
whisk up those eggs nicely
[Music]
then add peas to the pan
and to give the dish a wonderful
aromatic freshness some fragrant chopped
basil
i want to chop that sort of roughly
because i want to see those flecks of
green going in
i want it looking charming and how many
times have you seen a
dull omelet
frittatas in my mind really helped
encapsulate the magic of having
savory eggs
cooked beautifully
but with texture
now just before we add the eggs
i've got this
beautiful little goat's cheese and it's
strong and powerful
so i want to slice it
into little chunks
and then just
have it
dotted around i want to discover these
little pockets of creamy goat's cheese
now slowly
add the eggs
[Music]
fill that right up
and get your spoon
now just let all that egg go down to the
bottom
bring it back up to the boil and sort of
clean around the sides and then some of
this delicious
salty
creamy goat's cheese over the top
now
i want it melting like a
perfect slice
of cheese on toast
nice
now
from there turn the grill on for four to
five minutes
[Music]
now
just looking at that
delicious
take a little paring knife and just
make sure
it's released
on the sides
just take your panel
tap
that will hopefully release the frittata
from the bottom of the pan
now
abort over the panel
turn that
gently
and just
shake
say a little prayer
and lift off back
beautiful
now
from there
on
there it's there look
now
slice
through
you can see
how soft and creamy that is in the
center
and that goat's cheese is just melting
almost like a little sauce inside it's
so exciting but more importantly so easy
to do
it's got texture it's got creaminess and
that for me will beat any omelette for
brunch
serve with a stack of hot butter toast
and a steaming pot of coffee this easy
frittata turned the humble egg into the
perfect dish for kicking off the weekend
[Music]
pan on
get that nice and hot
you think of the sort of density of a
pork chop how it needs a little bit of
help
sweet sound peppers go brilliantly well
first slice the peppers that's the flat
side of the pepper so stand it up trying
to slice a pepper
on the side is a nightmare there's the
center
start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange go all the way around
and down
and look that's what you want
now place the pepper down
three finger rule one finger in front
two behind
pinky holding it down thumb holding it
nice and flat the flatter the vegetables
the more confident you are when you
slice so
don't worry about the speed
just let the knife do the work
and take your time
speed comes
the most important thing
is to get your technique right
red onion
now sweet sour peppers
olive oil in
i'm going to saute them which is just
the chef's turn for shallow frying on a
high heat for maximum taste
some salt and pepper
add a tablespoon of sugar sugar helps to
break down the peppers quicker but
caramelize the onions frying them in a
frying pan perfect it's one of the sort
of basic essential tools of any kitchen
because it's so multi-purpose
great for sauteing
tossing
great for cooking fish on meat
push away and pull back push away and
pull back that hissing is something you
need to hear constantly because
the minute that's gone your peppers and
your onions start to boil and you really
want them to soak in
you now start to see it glistening in
the way that it's starting to caramelize
sugar's working beautifully
that's ready for the red wine vinegar
in
smells incredible it helps to stain the
peppers as well look at the glaze now
you can see the sugar
it's worked as magic
turn down the gas and add a couple of
tablespoons of fresh
extra virgin olive oil
let them stew for two to three minutes
now i want to make the peppers nice and
light and sort of sweet aromatic
just roll the basil
almost like a big cigar
slice
basil in and then literally cook it out
for 30 seconds i want them off
beautiful
okay pan back on
now for the pork chops
i want to make sure
they don't curl up in the pan they start
curling up in the pan they're going to
cook unevenly
a few simple cuts through the rind means
the chop stays flat and cooks evenly
point the knife down
flip through this seasoned beautifully
nice large
shards of pepper punch that through
lightly guaranteed that seasoning
is gonna stay there
hot pan touch garlic and touch of thyme
the garlic
take a couple of cloves
don't peel it don't chop it just knife
on
crush it
olive oil in
just starting to smoke
top of the chop
in
and lay away from me
nice
keep that heat in the pan
put the garlic in there early
a nice fragrant bunch of thyme
see how the pork is staying nice and
flat
turn that over look at that beautiful
i want a little bit of thyme underneath
there
start squeezing that garlic out i want
the flavor coming out
butter in
thin slices of butter
tilt the pan and baste
so i'm sort of speeding up the cooking
process at the same time i'm keeping the
pork chop really nice and moist
and now look at the color that butter
it's almost like sort of a nut brown
check the color on the other side useful
when they're that thick
three and a half to four minutes each
side 30 seconds from now they're going
to be medium so i'm going to take them
out and let them rest
the secret to perfectly moist pork chops
is letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in the pan
[Music]
a nice spoon
of these peppers the basil smells
incredible
keep that garlic on there be generous
with that vinaigrette from the peppers
because it really is incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers
and your confidence is gonna shoot
through the roof a stunning pork chop
with sweet and sour peppers